the man accused of killing four
University students near campus is now
in County Jail in Idaho he was handed
over to local authorities after a flight
from Pennsylvania Omar villafranca has
more from Moscow Idaho
Landing in Washington late Wednesday
night 28 year old Brian coburger was met
by law enforcement on the Pullman Moscow
Regional Airport tarmac
he was quickly escorted to the Leda
County Jail in Moscow Idaho where he was
booked on four counts of first-degree
murder for allegedly killing Kaylee
gonsalves Madison Mogan Zana kernodle
and Ethan Chapin in November hello how
y'all doing it coburger's arrival in
Idaho came as police released new body
cam video of the suspect and his dad
being pulled over twice in Indiana on a
December road trip home to Pennsylvania
be right up on the back of that thing
video shows the sheriff's deputy talking
with the two about their long drive if
you're coming from Washington State
University
[Music]
[Music]
more than two weeks after this coburger
was arrested at his family's home in
Pennsylvania the public defender for his
extradition case Jason labar described
him to 48 hours as calm and intelligent
he's an ordinary man to me I see no
distinct characteristics he's easy to
talk to he's aware of the situation he's
very calm
coburger is is expected in court as
early as this morning we just don't have
official word yet now at his initial
appearance he'll hear the charges
against him but he won't have to enter a
plea Nate
Omar thank you and 48 hours we'll have
more on this case in an episode called
the Idaho student murders this Saturday
at 10 9 Central